this is the third lecture
in my series on the birth of tragedy
what we've done so far is we've looked
at these these two notions the
apollonian and the dionysian and how
they worked out in greek culture
what they were in themselves how they
could enter and sort of interplay the
fact that they were not the only
possible responses
to the problem of life as nietzsche
thought then we talked about
tragedy itself how tragedy developed
particularly with these two guys
ashley's
and sophocles the tragic vision of
things how it
in some ways fused or united or brought
into dialectical
both opposition and productive tension
these two forces of the outboarding and
the dynasiac
which elements conform to what you know
remember the chorus is dionysian
dionysiak and the dialogue is alone
where we have to go now is to look at a
third possible response to the problem
of life which comes to supplant
both the apollonian and the dionysiak
and comes to produce
what nietzsche calls tragedy's death
it's not enough to call a piece of
tragedy or they have a certain structure
to it
for it to actually be tragedy in
nature's eyes
it has to have this this interconnection
of the apollonia
and the dionysian and it can't just have
traits of that it actually has to have
those
running through it and nietzsche thinks
that there's a dramatic cultural shift
that takes place
in the plays of euripides and also in
the figure of socrates towards what he
calls
alexandrian culture
so that's what we're focusing on today
we're looking at sections 11 through 17
primarily the undoing of the dynamic
synthesis
between the dnsc act and the apollonia
and the replacement
culturally in greek culture
by the socratic alexandrian response
so this is a response that nation
identifies in particular
with euripides as a playwright also with
the new comedy
with plato and his teacher socrates
and with alexandrian culture what do
what does he mean by alexandrian culture
very often we make a distinction between
hellenic and hellenistic and hellenistic
is the culture that comes about
after the or
through the conquests of alexander the
great
remember alexander the great is from
macedon which is a
semi-barbarous country to the north of
greece the greeks themselves
in the peninsula have been fighting
against each other for a long time
mastodon comes in takes them over under
philip of macedon who then is
assassinated
his son alexander takes over and what
does he do he takes on the ancient enemy
of
the greeks the great persian empire
conquers it takes over asia minor
the the levant the middle east
egypt alexandria is founded and
named after him the rest of the persian
empire was nowadays
iraq iran portions of afghanistan
pushes all the way to the boundaries of
india at which point his troops say
that we've got enough
he settles his his soldiers
throughout his his new kingdom and the
new states that arise there the
successor states
are deeply imbued with greek culture but
are they imbued
with classic greek culture or are they
imbued with something that's
in some ways more superficial
that's what nacho ask and
he thinks that the answer is the latin
that it's something that in some ways is
more superficial
and yet has a vitality of its own so
that's what we're going to look at today
he calls this antideonisiac
this socratic alexandrian response is
opposed to the dionysiak
in part because it doesn't truly
understand it the apollonian was also
opposed to the
dna but in a very different way remember
the apollonian
it establishes its own limits
and it doesn't push all the time it
doesn't try to destroy or wipe out the
venus yet
the socratic impulses to actually do so
um it tries to replace it with something
new and more valuable
something which would be completely true
completely good
completely consistent those become the
hallmark values
nietzsche in a later section writes the
alexandrian response
as one of three kinds of illusion
that answer only to noble natures so
this is a very important point to
stress and to rest on for a minute
nietzsche was not saying i made this
very clear in the first lecture
that all artwork is either apollonian or
dionysiac
that's not the case nor is all artwork
on a continuum of
oblong indianistiac nor is it all
necessarily a fusion of it
there can be some artwork that has no
apollonian or dnc elements to it
whatsoever
this is not an exclusive dichotomy
nor is the addition of the alexandrian
socratic response making it a trichotomy
so that everything would either be
this or this or this or a mixture of
those he says that these are responses
that correspond to noble natures
uh who resent the burden of existence
more deeply than the rest
and who therefore require special
deguilments to make them forget this
burden
what are some of the other possible
responses nietzsche would say that um
you know you could have sort of purely
mercenary
or slavish pursuits um which would not
actually for that be dionysian just
trying to forget things doesn't make you
a dionisian there has to be more
involved than
just drinking and having a good time
trying to gain power is not necessarily
apollonia
it could be just pursuing power for its
own sake not for the sake of
the true the beautiful the good which is
the socratic alexandrian
response in in large respect
the socratic response is something new
something
something bringing an originality to the
to the game
um it's novel
it is in that sense creative or
productive
but it's creative reproductive and kind
of
repressive or forgetful way
as well but
nietzsche does not see socrates as
merely what he calls an
agent of disintegration socrates is
contributing euripides is contributing
something
new something that nietzsche is
combating but something that he can
recognize as a novel
contribution socrates he says and this
is very important
is the vortex and the turning point of
western civilization
so that's actually answering a question
that may
occur to some some viewers or some
readers
why do we care about the greeks at all
why do we care about
all this apollonian dionysian euripides
uh you know aristocracy's view on him
nationalists all this this this
rigmarole isn't this all just old dead
white
well they're not actually white because
they're greek and the greeks had no
conception of themselves at the time
as as white versus you know something
else
um but isn't this sort of you know dead
white european male stuff
if we want to put into that that
paradigm how does this apply to anything
today
well you know nietzsche thinks that that
western civilization
in general and i think that you could
also read
other uh responses within modernity
outside of you know the sphere of a
european and american
you know liberal democracies and such i
think you could read some of this into
that
nietzsche thinks that what we're dealing
here is
something that has come to dominate
the modern mindset
the scientific mindset and he's looking
for something like this to come on the
scene
to replace it a renewal
that's why we want to study the greeks
because they have something
new today to contribute to this it's not
just about how to read
echelos and make sense of him better for
his own sake
it's about how to revive within a
culture that has become sort of imbued
with this socratic alexandrian point of
view
how to revive something that won't just
replicate that that will actually go
deeper to the roots of what it is that
we need as human beings
so socrates is the vortex and the
turning point of western civilization
how do we get there let's start with
euripides and tragedy what happened
and why did it happen and what were its
effects
so this is going to straight to the text
nietzsche says that tragedy dies
by suicide leaving a tremendous vacuum
um perished in a manner quite different
from its older sister
arts it died by suicide and consequence
of an insoluble
conflict while the others died serena
natural deaths had advanced
age what was this insoluble
conflict well we're going to get to that
in a moment that's going to arise
through socrates and euripides
what ends up being the effects this is
really interesting it says
when after all a new genre sprang into
being which honored tragedy as its
parent
the child was seen with this maid bare
indeed the features of its mother
but of its mother during her long death
struggle
the death struggle of tragedy had been
fought by euripides
well the later art is known as
new attic comedy pneumatic comedy will
go on to
play a major role in the roman world a
lot of early roman plays were just sort
of taking greek plays
and transposing them and new added
comedy probably that's
one of the closest things that we have
to it these days are bad sitcoms
where you have stock characters and
interesting things are happening but
they don't really have any great
significance
i suppose in a way if you take seriously
it's it's um claimed to be a show about
nothing
the seinfeld show could have been
something like
new comedy you know um
not even realistic in the sense of like
tearing down everything and destroying
values just sort of
nihilistically there that's the uh
that's the uh product that comes about
um now like it says new added comedy
follows in the wake of your reputation
brings the spectator onto the stage
uh it's the common man the individual
who
enjoys euripides drama and pneumatic
comedy why
because there's this enjoyment of
lowering uh
things to a more common
or ordinary level of seeing their selves
portrayed on the stage
um he says here's a contrast
once we realize out of what substance
the promethean dramatists before
euripides
formed their heroes how far it had been
from their thoughts to bring onto the
stage of true replica of actuality
we shall clear we shall see clearly how
utterly different were those
uh intentions of your rickety's through
him the common man found his way from
the auditorium onto
the stage odysseus the
typical greek of older art declined
under the hands of the new poet to the
characters of gracolas
who henceforth held the center of the
stage
and this is a grycalis the type the good
humored
cunning slave now every spectator could
behold his exact counterpoint a
counterpart on the european stage and
was delighted to find him so eloquent
this is another important
thing as well euripides is affecting the
culture
uh in part by as he says teaching people
how to speak
which is a phrase that's put into his
mouth
interestingly enough not by a new
comedian but by one of the old comedians
who is actually sort of pointing himself
against socrates and euripides and
defending
older tragedy against their their
new response and that is aristophanes
euripides is making some sort of claim
like that he says through him the
populace had learned to observe make
transactions and form conclusions
according to all the rules of art with
the utmost cleverness
it was through this revolution in public
discourse that the new
comedy became possible from now on the
stock phrases to represent
everyday affairs we're ready to hand
people are able to come up with cliches
to make sense out of their
their day-to-day existence and so art
begins to pervade
everyday existence because everyday
existence
begins to pervade art
and the highest of arts so
um the audience for new comedy like he
says
is now enlightened and prepared
they
are a crowd that euripides could serve
as a choir master for
and like it says as soon as this chorus
had acquired a competence in the
european key
the new comedy that chess-like species
of play
with its constant triumphs of triumphs
of cleverness and cunning and rose
meanwhile choir master euripides was the
object of folsom praise
with and what's going on here what is
the the effect
um it produces a kind
of facsimile of the greek
serenity that came with the apollonia
and even more with the mixture of the
odd one
and the dionysiac
he says is hellonisms supreme deities at
that point become wit
whim caprice the pleasure of the moment
the fifth of state
that of the slaves comes into its own at
least in point of attitude
and if it is now at all possible to
speak of greek serenity then it must
refer to the serenity of the slave
who has no difficult responsibilities no
high aims into whom nothing
past her future is of greater value than
the present
you know it's interesting um
when we talk about slavery for for
americans
the first association is typically to
to the slavery that we had prior to the
including during the time of the civil
war and that was pretty horrific that a
race-based slavery
that was used as an economic system to
prop up the south
and um which is tied into you know if
you look at the ideologies tied up in
all sorts of ideas of chivalry in the
south
along with all sorts of notions of the
other
to there to be exploited
slavery had its terrible aspects in the
ancient world
but slavery was also a widespread
institution as it has been in every
civilization
that reaches a certain point of
development until
modern times
in some ways slavery is more horrific in
modern times
just because it's not a ubiquitous
institution so when it occurs
it's much more
much more clear the opposition is
between freedom and slavery
now the slave in ancient society
didn't have a grate but they typically
didn't have a terrible unless they were
doing things like mining
lead or salt or you know working galleys
or things like that
so long as
you did your work you could probably
expect you know food
lodging you know some some guidance on
what to do in life
and even some degree of freedom
depending on what exactly your duties
were
and it freed you from having to think
about things
slaves don't run the society slaves
don't make the big decisions
so you know in some ways you you can be
much
more free and happy just letting
somebody else
call all the shots for you i mean if it
bothers you to think about this in terms
of slavery
think about the person who is suddenly
thrown into chaos
when their job that you know it's the
only job they actually
train for and planned on doing their
whole life
and is not particularly demanding once
you learn how to
to get by in it gets eliminated
and now suddenly they were very happy
before making a paycheck you know
see your friends at work and just you
know do what you need to do
don't think about economic forces don't
think about whether the company is
profitable or not
that's all for the owners to worry about
or the managers to worry about
i'm just a worker suddenly the job gets
eliminated
and the person becomes politically
conscious oh
we have to do something about this but
they lost their surrender what was the
serenity that they have
i'm just going to keep going ah not over
here
and i'll have my vacations my weekends
i'm not going to think about this or
where things are going
that's not going to bother me i can be
entertained i can be a consumer
as would also work well that would be
something analogous to what nietzsche is
talking about here
in terms of the slave mentality
uh to go back to the euripides now
urbanese does not
actually pander to the audience though
this is a really important point
euripides
is being criticized for pandering to the
lower class for
pandering to the common people some
people want to see in that you know sort
of democracy trying to think over
aristocracy or oligarchy well what's
actually going on
euripides is training the audience
for something that he himself is being
driven by
so he's not pandering to the audience
he's in some ways making the audience
come along with him
pandering to something else two other
audiences uh two spectators who are not
the crowd
so um
who is this this other spectator
let me read you this passage euripides
considered himself to be quite superior
to the crowd as a whole not however to
two of his spectators
he would translate the crowd onto the
stage but insist all the same on
reverencing the two members as the sole
judges of his art on following all their
directions and admonitions
and instilling in the very hearts of his
dramatic characters those emotions
passions and recognitions which
heretofore
seconded the stage action like an
invisible chorus from the series ranks
of the amphitheater
he was in deference to these judges that
he gave to the characters new characters
a new voice to
a new music their votes and no others
determined from the worth of his efforts
efforts of the two spectators i just
spoke of
was euripides himself but now notice
what nietzsche says here
the thinker euripides not the poet
so euripides is in fact a thinker
and that he's trying to translate this
into poetry
so he says endowed with such talent such
remarkable intellectual acidity and
versatility
euripides watch the performances of his
predecessor's plays and tried to
rediscover in them those fine lineaments
which age
as happens in the case of old paintings
and darkened and almost obliterated
euripides is a scholarly
spectatory playwright he
is observing the people who came before
him
and saying okay let's actually
watch this now what works here
how can i replicate that what's the
essence of this
this thing that works why does this work
why does this not work i i'm not just
going to get rid of this that this part
that doesn't work
i want to know why it doesn't work so i
can make sure i don't do things like
that
in other cases and what did euripides
actually learn well he says
euripides perceived in every line and
every trait something quite in
commence circle a certain deceptive
clarity
and together with it a mysterious death
and infinite background
what is that well
a certain deceptive clarity that's the
apollonia
together with a mysterious depth
infinite background that's the dionysiak
the clearest figure trailed after the
comet's tail which seemed to point to
something uncertain something which
could not be wholly elucidated
a similar twilight seemed to invest the
very structure of drama especially the
function of the chorus
so euripides you know is thinking about
these things
how do these work he's trying to bring
everything into the scrutiny
of the the spectator the perfect
spectator himself
and he says then again how ambiguous did
the solutions of all moral problems seem
how problematical the way in which the
mists were treated
how irregular the distributions of
fortune and misfortune
there was also much in the language of
older tragedy took
exception to why all this elevated
language these tropes and hyperboles
so there's you know the the apollonian
elements euripides doesn't really have
that big of a problem with the dionysiac
elements
he really does he doesn't fully
understand what's going on with them
and so his goal is to eliminate the dncm
and rebuild tragedy as better so think
of it as taking an old building and
you're going to
gut all the parts of it that don't seem
to be entirely
up to snuff but you didn't realize that
well that was a load-bearing wall
that you just tore down that's what ends
up happening according to nietzsche
who's the second spectator so that's
your ribbons the second spectator is
socrates and
euripides um
why is he so interested in
socrates himself well um
as nature says
first in a certain sense uribe is but a
mask
while the divinity which spoke through
him was neither dianisos nor apollo but
a brand new
damon called socrates then sport the
real antagonism was to be
it was to be between the dionysian
spirit and the socratic and tragedy was
to perish
in the conflict let us look now more
closely at the socratic tendency by
which by means of which euripides fought
and conquered ashley and tragedy
so euripides is is
trying to make sense out of things using
a mindset that is coming essentially
from socrates
and what happens to tragedy when you
pull the dionysiak
out it says once it was no longer
begotten by
music in the mysterious dnc and twilight
what form could drama conceivably take
only that of the dramatized epic
an apollonian form which precluded
tragic effects
so as we left off before
when you abandoned dionysus apollo is
soon going to
leave as well so
he asks what relationship can be said to
obtain between an ideal abalone drama in
the place of euripides
the same is obtained between the early
solemn rhapsodists
the rhapsodist being the one who
essentially reenacts the language
re-does the epic recites it
doing so calmly allowing people to
contemplate the images carried out in
words
so the early solemn rhapsodies and the
more recent variety described in plato's
iron
if you if you read plato's dialogue the
iron socrates is discussing with a wrap
so named ian who's just won some prizes
what is it that you do and he gets very
interesting descriptions and he says
how do you do you actually know anything
um
does homer know anything does anybody
that you're you're working with know
anything or is it all just by a sort of
divine inspiration
that ends up being the position but what
nietzsche has focused on here
is that this passage when i say
something sad my eyes fill with tears
if however what i say is terrible and
ghastly then my hair is down stands on
that and my heart beats lovely
now that's not
despite not being happening that's not a
pianistiac
response either it's not losing oneself
in sort of this primal ongoing drama
of life it's focusing in on the very
specific
when i talk about something sad my eyes
go with tears when i talk about this
particular
sad thing say penelope morning for
odysseus when she thinks that he's lost
that's going to be socratic
or eurypian
there's a loss of detachment a loss of
illusion and
when how is new tragedy going to exert
an effect
nietzsche talks about it having to use
novel stimulants
so like he says
it cannot possibly achieve the
obligating effects of the epic while on
the other hand it's severed all
connection with the dionysiak
so that in order to have any impact at
all it must seek out novel stimulants
which are to be found
neither in the apollonian nor in the dnc
realm where are they to be found then
this is a good example for showing that
apollonia and sei
are not exclusive exhausted categories
there are other things outside of them
novel stimulants
he says those stimulants are on the one
hand cold paradoxical ideas put in the
place of the avalonian contemplation
cold paradoxical ideas rather than
images that one looks at but doesn't try
to probe
all the way into the bottom on the other
hand fiery emotions put in place of the
dionysian transports
the last are splendidly realistic
counterfeits but neither ideas nor
affects are infused with the spirit of
true artists
so um what should we say about these
substitutions
is there something radically new going
on here it's not as if people didn't
feel
these things before so euripides is
bringing into
existence things that people already do
feel but perhaps hadn't put into poetry
this is doing subjective art like
nietzsche talked about last time when he
said that the
is only objective this becomes very
subjective
and not in the sense that everybody
makes it but what they do in the sense
that it's focused on the individual
subject
so um what else is going on
there's something that that nature calls
aesthetic socratism
and what does he mean by this it means
that there's certain maxims or certain
mottos
certain statements that you can take as
fundamentally basic
whatever is beautiful must also be
sensible what must make sense
knowledge alone makes men virtuous and
happy
and so if you if you have these as sort
of the backdrop
of your artistic vision you're going to
write plays very differently
than somebody who believes that reality
is ultimately at bottom
a set of conflicts and contradictions
in which each part by itself makes sense
but the whole
you know on its own does not make sense
if you if you have that sort of vision
then you can write like shakespeare does
or you can write
like kafka does or you can write like
um ashley's does
if on the other hand you think that
ultimately
whatever is to be beautiful must be
sensible knowledge alone makes men
virtuous
and therefore happy then you have no
other choice that's right as euripides
does
and so euripides
becomes the first rational maker of
tragedy
nature says
so let's now switch and talk about
socrates the second spectator
there's a very interesting digression by
my nature
how socrates and euripides are similar
and connected with each other
he says
aristophanes treats both men in half
indignant half contemptuously
this may of the rising generation
the rising generation were willing to
sacrifice euripides and they could not
forget the picture of socrates of the
arch
sofas so they end up taking revenge on
aristophanes why does aristophanes
connect them together
like he says it was socrates who
expressed most clearly this radically
new prestige of knowledge and conscious
intelligence
when he claimed to be the only one who
acknowledged himself that he knew
nothing
he roams all over athens running across
poets politicians rhapsodes
householders other you know other
philosophers and sophists
and what does he do each time he sort of
tears them down
and gets them to have to admit that
whether they like it or not that they
actually don't know what they claim to
know
there's a new idea there's there's a
along with this ideal
setting knowledge way up here in a
conscious life a life
that would be sort of you know pure
lucidity
everything else gets gets pushed down
everything else gets lower
particularly anything that has some
mystery some some shadow to it
and so there's a denigration or demotion
of other people other disciplines
other ways of life as not having
knowledge
as getting by on instinct or knack
something unconscious something that
can't give as plato has soccer to say it
can't give an account
of itself now this is not just an
opposition between a new ideal of
knowledge
and an actuality of non-knowledge it's
not just somebody going around and
saying
i really want to know what everybody
else knows what they see if they do know
anything
and then finding that they don't then
saying yeah i guess none of us know
anything
there's a desire here there's a demand
here something consuming
something that that in some ways lights
a fire
you might think of socrates speech at
the apology where he says you know
you kill me and other people are going
to come along and do the same thing as
me but they're not going to be so nice
so maybe you ought to think twice about
killing me
he's making a real threat socrates
ignites a movement um
what is this movement aimed at doing not
just pointing out
failures or lacks of
pure knowledge understanding it's aimed
at correcting the situation
that's the drive that's what's most
productive
in this socratic euripidean
alexandrian response and
so socrates is the the spectator
imagine what he's going to bring to
tragedy anything that doesn't make
pure sense is probably something that
you have to get rid of if you want to be
rational about it right
the reactive character of socrates
diamond is
the logical side becomes hypertrophy the
the instinctive sign the dionysiac side
becomes purely negative
rather than positive
what does socrates actually see in
tragedy he sees it as
fundamentally irrational not
communicating truth
as misrepresenting things
except for word euripides tragedy
which is supposed to be representing
things as they really are not mythically
not uh leaving you know things that you
have to
ferret or figure out yourself so the
features of tragedy
that are there that are dionysiac in
the socratic view of the music the
chorus
as as nietzsche says optimistic
dialectics took up the width of its
syllogisms and drove music out of
tragedy
and we'll come back to the socratic
approach there's one digression that
nietzsche makes
regarding plato that i think is very
important to talk about as well
um there's a reason why i put
platonic dialogue here with the ribbity
and tragedy of the ancient comedy
plato starts out as a poet
and an athlete too by the way plato you
know brought back
he's a big guy he's also a noble
but he's a poet he wants to be a tragic
poet
he burns his poetry his youthful efforts
why because he's captivated with this
man
and the way of life that he's putting
forth the ideal that he's
he's putting for him he develops a new
art form as nietzsche says deeply akin
to the existing forms which he had
repudiated
if you read platonic dialogues and it
may
sometimes depending on the translation
take reading them in the greek for this
to come out
the best one by the by by the way for
the examples of this is the symposium
you will see plato actually taking bits
and pieces
of all sorts of other forms of poetry
all other genres and weaving them into
his own dialogue not just poetry too by
the way medical treaties you know for
example with eric simicus
in the symposium oratory like the
redders
he weaves gorgian rhetoric into
agathon speech he takes a speech by
lysius and actually
brings that whole thing into the
phaedras and has them discussing it
platonic dialogue is
assimilative it takes the other forms of
poetry but it it
also breaks them down in part it loses
something of their
their spirit and it misunderstands them
and reaches you
tragedy had assimilated the previous
artistic genres
epic nietzsche doesn't talk about this
but epic i think can arguably
be said to have done something similar
now plato would do something along the
same lines only raised to a higher level
so it becomes a mixture of all the other
poetry
and nietzsche makes a very strange
remark
at a certain point he says plato has
furnished for all posterity the pattern
of a new art
for the novel viewed as the essopian
fable raised to the highest power
so he's saying and i think when somebody
like nietzsche says something like this
given the fact that he was a philologist
a class assistant he spent so much time
thinking about this
when he says that the platonic dialogue
somehow leads to the novel the early
novel
in the alexandria culture i think maybe
there's something worth we're thinking
about there we can't dwell on this
very much but it is worth noting
what happens with the abalone and the
dionysian
socrates like he says becomes the
dialectical hero
so once um the
socrates the dialectical hero the
platonic drama
shows a close affinity to the erympedian
hero who is compelled to justify his
actions by proof and counterproof
and for that reason is locker in danger
of forfeiting our tragic compassion
for who among us can close his eyes to
the optimistic
element in the nature of dialectics
which sees a triumphant every syllogism
and can breathe only in an atmosphere of
cool conscious clarity
stop and think for a moment if you've
read them
about the picture of socrates as he's
about to die
in the credo and in the fade
is that tragic or is it optimistic
does it arouse in us sympathy
is it does it awaken our feelings in a
sense or is it trying to
get us uh to go away from them towards
the life of
the intellect nietzsche goes up
once that optimistic element had entered
tragedy overgrew its dionysia regions
and brought about their annihilation and
finally the leap
into gentile domestic drama consider the
consequences of the socratic maxims
virtue is knowledge
all sins arise from ignorance only the
virtuous are happy
these three basic foundations of
optimism spell the death of tragedy
the virtuous hero must henceforth be a
dialectician
virtue and knowledge belief and ethics
be necessarily and demonstrably
connected
actually transcendental concept of
justice
reduced to the brash and shallow
principle of poetic justice
with its regular deus ex machina
so that is going to end up
destroying tragedy
so the socratic approach virtue and
knowledge belief and ethics have to be
necessarily demonstrably connected
socrates is sort of the model
of the new theoretical man whose
significance and aims we
nature says we must now attempt to
understand like the artist
theoretical man takes infinite pleasure
in all that exists and
is thus saved from the practical ethics
of pessimism
while the artist having unveiled the
truth garment by government remains with
his gaze
fixed on what is still hidden
theoretical man
takes delight in the garments
in the cast garments and finds his
highest satisfaction in the unveiling
process itself
which proves to him his own power it's
there's an experience
you've probably all experienced this
when you've studied something and it
made sense to you
and you work through something
there's sort of a deep-seated illusion
that nature thinks is
integral to the theoretical man and
to the scientific
attitude and the modern scientific
technological consumerist culture
it says some type of deep-seated
illusion first manifest in socrates
the illusion that thought guided by the
threat of causation
might plumb the farthest of this as a
being and even correct it
so whereas the apollonian and the
dionysian are responses to the problem
of being
ultimately remember what is being for
nietzsche
it has no meaning it just is and we're
stuck with that
the socratic response says we can do
something about that
we can fix that we can create
meaning we can discover the meaning that
that is truly there
it's optimistic in that way
this grand metaphysical illusion
nietzsche says has become integral to
the scientific and
endeavor and again again leads science
to those far limits of its inquiry
where it becomes art which in this
mechanism
is what is really intended that's a
really brilliant thing to notice on
aegis part
we often think of scientists as being
sort of you know passionless
dominated by the intellect
nietzsche is saying no the scientific
endeavor itself
is just as fully engaged in terms of the
desires the emotions
affectivity the heart and that's what
allows the scientists to actually
do the work that he or she does
very often counter intuitively and to
think yeah this is going to pay off
you know so he says if we examine
socrates in the lightest
light of this idea he strikes us as the
first who is able not only to live
under the guidance of that instinctive
scientific certainty but to die by it
to be a martyr to it for this reason the
image of the dying socrates mortal man
freed
by knowledge and argument from the fear
of death is the emblem which hanging
above the portal of every science
reminds the adept his mission is to make
existence appear intelligible
is very important appear intelligible
and thereby justified and
here you know it's another thing too if
you go through the whole thing in
dialectics and science and knowledge and
understanding
can't get you to that point where not
only everything makes sense but also
makes sense in a bigger in a bigger way
you know it's it's not only
intelligible but justifiable
well then that's when you go and use
myth
that's when you tell a story that's what
mythos means story
that's when you laugh into poetry again
now he says um
under this viewpoint everything comes to
be seen as
teachable as knowable and in a way
that's to deform the reality of certain
things
now one of the things that could be a
response to this
is um what he calls a
pessimistic response which schopenhauer
takes and also he sees in buddhism and
hinduism
and other certain cultural responses
um against this practical pessimism he
says socrates represents the archetype
of the theoretical optimist
who's strong in the belief that nature
can be fathomed considers knowledge to
be the true panasan error to be the
radical evil
now what is the result of this
we have a culture where like he says
since the time of socrates the mechanism
of concepts judgments and syllogisms has
come to be regarded
as the highest exercise of man's power
if there is the best part of us what is
that's always been a classic discussion
for the socratic response it's the
intellect the intellect disengaged from
from all of this other stuff
nature's most admirable gift socrates
and his successors down to our own day
have considered
all moral and sentimental
accomplishments noble deeds
compassion self-sacrifice
heroism even that spiritual calm which
the
babylonian greek called sulfurosane to
be ultimately derived from the dialectic
of knowledge and therefore teachable
and he says if we look about today we
shall see how the insatiable zest for
knowledge
prefigured in socrates what does it have
what is it done in our civilization
it has been transformed into tragic
resignation of the need for art
while uh all to be sure on a lower level
that same zest appears hostile to all
art
and especially to the truly tragic
dionysian art as i've tried to show
paradigmatically in this version of
echelon art by socratism
this is where nature thinks that people
in his time
around you know the 1870s
i would say this continues all the way
through to his death
think that we we are this is what he's
been later on call
the contemporary problem of nihilism
the question that we have to ask at this
point
is is this socratic alexandrian response
going to remain
ascendant and there's a suggestion
in section 17. i'm skipping over section
16 where he talks about schopenhauer's
use because it mentions
the time right now there's a suggestion
the tragedy can only be reborn when
science the scientific view the
scientific attitude the socratic
alexander's been pushed to its limits
and renounce claims to universal
validity
and has that happened had that
happened in his time uh has it
happened in ours what would be going on
there a culture that orients itself
fundamentally around these ideals would
realize itself as hollow as corrupt
as not measuring up that would free
or rather that would open the situation
to a resurgence of something which
would be like tragedy apollonian and
dnac fusing them together something that
would go
beyond that and that is what nietzsche
wants nietzsche's thought he saw
something like that happening in his own
time
so that's what we're going to talk about
in the next
video how these different responses play
themselves out in
modern culture we've talked about the
greeks now at great length
now we want to see how it plays out in
the modern culture of nietzsche's time
and we want to see how it plays out if
we can
in the late modern culture of our own
time
so that's what we'll leave off